hello everybody welcome back to our
little astro
coffee bookshelf hangout we haven't
exactly changed the name yet
i'm still using the astro coffee hangout
uh
branding but we're gonna change that
soon my name is tony darnell i
live work and breathe at
deepastronomy.com and this is our
hangout where that we have where we
introduce you to some really cool stuff
going on on dr brian keating shannon
wow is that me yeah
hang on i've got this i
that was a newbie uh newbie error
sorry about that uh i had i had the
stream going in one of the
one of the windows and i shouldn't have
and i didn't have it muted so
apologies newbie hangout that used to
happen to me all the time
anyway this is this is let me let me go
ahead and pull up my my
friend and colleague dr brian keating hi
brian it's good to have you here
tell us a little bit about what we're
doing here i'll let you do it since i'm
blowing it today ah you're not blowing
it
you're under uh you're under great
duress
you're pretty good okay yeah so yeah
technical duress that's let's
say that so i am brian keating a
professor of physics here i'll advertise
i got my new shirt ucsd department of
physics ooh that's neat
yeah it's got uh all of our uh greatest
and latest
graphic design on it which we'll
eventually put to the test on
coming up with a logo and an icon for
these hangouts but yeah
for now i love your i love your uh the
current graphics
so uh every week i run a podcast an
interview
or an event here at uc san diego even
during the covet emergency
we've been running interviews and
dialogues with some of the greatest
minds in the world ranging from
science to artists to to leaders and
i'll be doing some interviews in the
coming weeks with biographers
and really journalists that have
detailed the most interesting
uh items in society both in science and
and beyond
so next week i'm interviewing sarah
fryer who is a journalist for bloomberg
and she wrote a book about the story of
instagram
and uh we'll talk about that maybe at
some point but it's a little bit you
might think it's off topic
but actually a lot of the lessons that
she brings up in that book
have great applicability for uh projects
in
astronomy and cosmology and particle
physics all the sorts of things that i'm
interested in so
uh stay tuned for that but this week
we're talking uh to a household name the
first family of astronomy and the cosmos
and that's of course sasha sagan and she
is the daughter of none other than they
kind of are the first family aren't they
yeah that's right yeah i don't i don't
know if bill nye has any kids or
i think male 1 no no no sorry it's got
to be carl sagan
yeah that's right actually he started
the planetary society where bill nye
currently presides yep he's definitely
the guy so
um i interviewed sasha sagan about two
weeks ago and we put together a special
mother's day edition
of my podcast my podcast called the into
the impossible podcast
and i um as i said i run out of videos
and so forth
on a weekly basis and her episode came
out on mother's day and we talked a lot
about
um about being a mother or being a
parent and
the traditions that were passed on by
her great parents
carl sagan and andrew right and so
um uh
so all of these so i just want to remind
everybody that the um
that uh the links to brian's channel and
the interview that he did with sasha
sagan is in the description box of this
video so please go watch it after
you watch this preview for it and um i
some of you are asking
am i am i am i streaming on twitch and
the answer is no
not today uh i'm trying to be nice
twitch gets mad when you
stream things to it that you're also
streaming to someone else
so i'm not streaming to twitch today but
i am streaming uh everywhere else
uh as well i'm on facebook and and we're
also streaming this on brian's channel
so please
uh subscribe to him and uh check it out
there as well so
you can comment on his channel uh in the
live chat also
so um uh okay so let's see
uh let's go ahead and start with do you
want to start with one of your clips or
do you want to
enter okay all right which one i'll do
the
all right let me
we haven't heard yet from from e.t and
we also talked about
um about the origin of the title of her
book
and another thing we talked about is how
different scientific
and non-scientific aspects of our place
in the cosmos
affect the rituals that we as human
beings carry out she's very
much a secular atheist herself as were
her parents
but she observes an awful lot of of
rituals and i was fascinated
to learn of what prompted her to do that
and um
and also share with her some of my um
you know sort of contrary and you know
ideas to hers contrary ideas to hers
but i think we uh we reach a great deal
of conciliants in the
discussion oh good okay i'll start the
script and then i want to remind you
brian's going to be around we'll talk
about this for about a half an hour then
he's got to go and then i'll hang around
for
questions and comments after the fact so
here we go let me start with this first
one
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence is coming from
uh looking originally comes from you
know jody foster
jill tarter hearing this uh radio
impulses on a large radio telescope the
very large array it's a wonderful
facility
but she hears it using radio signals uh
after you know we're now celebrating
basically the 60th year
of the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence with which your dad was
deeply involved
and i wonder what would he say about the
state you know we haven't found anything
and you know you're a big believer in
evidence and belief
but you know we have no evidence that
they exist positive evidence
at what point you know would he give up
uh do you think or would you let's just
say personally
at what point do you turn the telescopes
off because we don't have infinite
resources on this
powerless planet um you know when do you
give up a search
and and just reside with the feeling
that you may never know
well we may never know whether we search
or
or we don't but i think that um
it's very it's an answer to a deep and
profound question
to know if this is if it's just us or
not and
you know um i think my dad's curiosity
about that was very profound
and minus two and again you know this is
one of those things where
people would say what come up to him and
say well what do you think and he would
say i don't know
um and they would say yeah but like what
does your gut tell you and he would say
i try not to use my gut for this sort of
thing i try to use my mind
and um i think you know it is an
important question and is a profound
question and
and as long as we can try to gain a
little more evidence
um i think whatever the answer is
we it's nothing we could possibly guess
and so it is worth
trying to find out and it tells us
either way the answer tells us so much
about ourselves
okay so that's a little preview into the
the conversation that he had with sasha
um
so how did that go i mean you guys spoke
for for about how long how long did you
talk to her on this
over an hour we actually uh she was very
generous with her time and it was kind
of funny the way that it
materialized i just reached out to her
online and asked her
you know would you mind being on my
podcast i've had on some of your friends
and
and colleagues and she said she said yes
and
came on and i read her book listened to
her book
and um it worked out really nicely
because you know she she's jewish as i
said she's jewish in the same way
you know one of my uh people i listen to
on the internet aj
jacob says you know she's jewish but
kind of in the way that olive garden is
italian you know it's not
she's culturally uh affiliated with
judaism she observes you know
her own versions of certain rituals in
judaism as your listeners may know i'm
jewish and i'm a practicing jew
um uh not that you know the far extreme
of of you know practice but
but it is an important part of my life
and the rituals that i connect to
uh are she connects to in a very
different way she connects to them quite
frankly
in a way that's more naturalistic in
that she observes
holidays in the springtime because she
feels a great deal of kinship say with
the fact that those holidays have been
observed for thousands of years
and they themselves owe to the fact that
the earth is tilted on its axis
by some 23 degrees and if not for that
we would have
no seasons and so she connects the
cosmic to the
um to the psychological to the to the uh
societal
and draws great distinctions and all
sorts of things united by this
um the essence of all these things the
commonality is time
and repetition periodicity so much so
she talks about her own monthly cycles
and very graphic the book is is
it's um it's very uh she's very exposed
in this book i mean she talks about the
first time
uh she uh had relations with her future
husband i mean it was really intimate
and
shockingly so but i commend her for that
i mean she's a public famous person
and yet she and it's not gratuitous
she's not like going you know getting
graphic or
anything but she's talking about you
know as a human being
but also as a scient science curious um
lay person she's not a scientist uh who
grew up around these two towering
figures on the two opposite poles of
science
and and art if you will
so i mean i guess more than i i hear
what you're saying when you talk about
judaism in the way that you just did i
was married to someone who was jewish
and uh the the i think more than any
other
religion culture that i've been involved
with um
there is there does seem to be this
component where there's a cultural
component where the rituals are very
important
and then there is a more religious
component where those rituals tie into
their beliefs in in god
and uh so i see those those connections
and it is it does seem to be
for a lot of jewish people at least um
you're able to enjoy the culture and the
holidays and the rituals that are
associated
with judaism and it seems like you're
not necessarily getting
uh super um religious about it and is
that what she means when she's talking
about secular rituals help me understand
what that means because
yes we have rituals that are that go
around the seasons in many cases
especially early on those were based on
a religious a religion of of of some
kind
so i guess i'm i'm curious as to what
that term
really means because i don't i don't it
doesn't make sense to me
yeah i mean that was the goal of the
book which i agree with you it's
ambitious and again i
i never like to give away kind of the
book i want authors to benefit from
people buying it but the main thrust of
the book
is to for the first time answer the
question that you're talking about which
is that can you be
spiritual without religion and if so how
now there are other authors i've read
like phil
zuckerman you know basically um writes a
lot about secular religion the rise of
the nuns n-o-n-e-s
um and in sasha's book she wants to kind
of um
in some ways have her cake and eat it
too because she wants she recognizes
that these rituals all derive from
religious um observance on the other
hand so too did things like astrology
and so she won't like directly or
pantheism she actually you know we talk
a little bit and uh
you know aren't you worried i asked her
you know you could have a devolution
back to
a more primitive form of you know gods
and goddess not worshipping
thor or you know literally but
worshiping
earth actually yeah some people yeah no
that's right i
i talked towards just a couple days
after earth day and we made mention of
that in the end right
and she uh she she definitely wants to
strike a very
um ecumenical stance her husband is
christian or grew up in a christian
household
we make the distinction that you know
she and i can take a genetic test for
better or for worse and they'll tell us
that we're no 99.97
you know eastern european jew but her
husband can't i mean he'll say you know
a little bit of scottish and a little
bit of you know
cherokee uh native america you know
whatever he's he's his
genetic background is but that too to
her is beautiful that this story that
we're kind of part of this chain
that goes back and even she's trying to
get the reasons for the rituals
um deriving from secular but then
divorcing it from
any connection to belief and what she
doesn't believe she has evidence for
again she's not a scientist and her
husband her father of course was a
scientist
but uh but by by any means i think the
the level of depth
that he would practice religion versus
looking for evidence in science
i think those are vastly different for
him and i think you know he was
known for statements like you know um
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence
and then uh you know extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
and yet they would have a passover seder
you know these these springtime
uh jewish uh religious uh rituals
uh i think in some cases there is a
little bit of dissonance there cognitive
dissonance that that
you want to take as i said have your
cake and eat it too right i'm glad you
said that
yeah and and and having you know believe
making everything from scratch i pressed
around and i said
you take these rituals to heart but what
if your daughter her book is dedicated
to her daughter
right um helena and her daughter you
know really
plays a big role in this book even
though at the time of the writing she
was like nine months old or something
but it's really like passing on from
mother to daughter which is why i
published the interview on mother's day
but at the same time i said what if she
doesn't what if she doesn't believe what
you believe or practice these rituals
that you've practiced for one generation
now how will that affect you you know
look at christianity
it's been around for thousands of years
i always joke you know
the bible's the best selling book in
history i'd kill for one percent of
god's sales
figures you know that would be a dream
come true
but on the same token she's um she's
very candid and i think you know i think
she wrestles with these questions and
and the listeners can can judge from the
interview and and uh
we can also always you know follow up
she's very responsive and
and i i really enjoy it she's incredibly
gracious
uh she's a thinker um and i think she
wants to have positions that are
different from her father but it's
impossible with a person like that
whose father casts such a huge shadow
yeah that's a lot
of life to not be influenced by it you
know and i feel like
she was almost born atheist you know
just by nature of how she grew up
and so um so we discussed that and and
to what extent would she be disappointed
if her daughter you know doesn't take on
the secular rituals that she's
developed with her husband so uh yeah
i'm really glad you said that
the the this idea of kind of having your
cake and eat it too because i think this
is a bit
problematic uh when you try to apply
scientific thought to
some of these non-scientific ideas and
some of these non-uh
non-uh i won't call them religious ideas
but
they the idea of ritual and why we do
these things sure there can be a
scientific component to it
and why we do them may have some kind of
answer in in a rational way that pleases
us
but i i think an awful lot of this is
coming from a place that isn't
necessarily scientific i've argued many
many times
that the danger we fall into especially
scientists and especially as people who
love science is that we fall into a
danger
of of trying to inject science where it
isn't
it isn't not only needed but appropriate
it's not even appropriate to put science
in these things
so about in all of this it it's
it's important that we understand first
of all what do we mean by spirituality
what does that even mean
and second of all what do we mean by a
ritual and
you know um maybe maybe spirituality
is uh not necessarily the thrust of this
book but
ritual certainly is so a a ritual can be
anything right it can be
a fact that you like to watch the same
tv show every week you know that can be
a ritual so
and they're and it's funny because they
are meaningful to us as human beings i
love
doing certain things right i mean i
really love having
a certain thing at thanksgiving to eat
it just it's really fun to have that
stuff but it's just fun
i used to love passover doing the seder
it was a
big lot of work but man it was fun to be
together
and read the haggadah and and have all
these um
you know for me it was i mean i'm not i
was non-jewish so
for me it was a look into this culture
and i was just
i was just having a blast you know it
was fun we were drinking wine we were
having for friends and family
uh it was a great it was a great seder
so
i don't know i guess maybe it's a group
thing the fact that we like to do
this kind of stuff but i also have
rituals that i like to do all by myself
right exactly you know that's a hundred
percent so
i think maybe you're a listener i mean
this is like the second or third time i
mean i love talking about
religion i think it's you know the key
question uh in all life is talking
not believing i would never say belief
is but thinking about these questions of
existence are the most important things
you and i talk about it almost every
week and i know some of the chat people
in the chat room don't like it so maybe
we'll move off it i do want to say one
thing
i i had the exact same question so when
you watch the video pay
careful attention because i make this
distinction which would you rather have
i asked her
a ritual a habit a hobby
or uh or willpower in other words like
on the spectrum
of obligations like when i tell my kids
they can't eat that delicious you know
baby back rib
um you know platter at a restaurant
because it's pork in it um you know
that i all i have to say is it's not
kosher and it carries a lot more weight
than if i say
you're on a diet you know i'm always on
a diet but you know when you
rely on willpower versus a habit so
there's three different
you know degrees of of placement on the
spectrum her husband
to my chagrin you know makes her coffee
every morning and or you know to my
wife's sugar in right
so you know and that's like she's like
that's our ritual and i'm like
is it a rich it's a ritual but you know
where does it stand with respect to
like you know she she makes she
discusses you know the origin
of of you know a female connection to
the monthly cycle and how that's a
ritual and how
that affects things you know in
inter-female dynamics
like that's obviously very different you
know someone if he didn't make you
coffee one day or you're on the road
it's not going to be
like my kids start eating you know ham
sandwiches
so i asked her about that exactly and
and where she rakes these things because
in the end i want i worry
if you're just relying on these on these
personal rituals habits you know getting
your morning coffee
like then anything could be a habit
anything could be a ritual
right there's rituals and habits yeah
that's good and what did aristotle say
he said
we are what we habitually do and i think
if you feel that way you know is change
possible and and she makes a big deal in
her book about how her grandfather gave
up
being an orthodox practicing jew and how
liberating that was and how it set her
family
on a certain path but on another hand
you know you could see it as
well who is more free like the person
who does whatever he wants to do like
eats whatever he wants to do
he drinks as much alcohol as he wants or
the person who's disciplined
who has willpower and self-control and
maybe that derives from
you know in some sense this this longer
ritual which we call religion
or not so i think your listeners will be
fascinated i do want to talk about
um his um carl and and
sasha's opinions about extraterrestrial
and astronomical rituals if you want to
talk about that yeah let's do it we've
got to go with 10 minutes so go for it
yeah i
got i can go up to 35 past the hour too
oh all right cool
if you could because i also want to know
just how famous she thinks
carl sagan was i mean but we'll go into
that if we have time so please
go ahead i have a doll you know i've got
a little finger puppet with carl sagan
on it i mean he's incredibly famous she
knows that
the thing that really struck me about
her is the great graciousness that she
has
she doesn't have like a ch like she
doesn't mind being described as carl
sagan's daughter
like if someone described me you know as
just my son or like
the you know describes my wife as the
wife of brian keating i think
that could be i would maybe be offended
or or you know denies my
identity she's very comfortable with the
fact that she is not only
carl sagan's daughter but also andrean's
daughter and
bill nye in her in his blurb i read it
you know that
that you know it shows or maybe it was
richard dawkins one of the two gentlemen
wrote a blurb for her both of them wrote
blurbs but one of them says
she's carl sagan's daughter and it shows
but i made the point that she's more
like andrean's daughter like andrean is
not a scientist
she's incredibly passionate she's a
wonderful writer great communicator
she's now doing cosmos possible worlds
that's right and i urge people to watch
that because sasha actually makes a
cameo as her own grandmother in that
in the new series which is kind of cute
so growing up in this family like she
had
she has these artifacts these relics of
of her of her unique upbringing you know
she talked to me about like she'll find
like the rosetta stone
used in the original cosmos you know
it's like some styrofoam thing in the
1980s that they painted
you know and engraved as if it's the
rosetta stone and she talks about you
know like
how many kids grow up with with parents
like that and how
they weren't i mean i don't get the
sense that if she decided to become an
evangelical christian that they would be
happy with it
um or you know practicing jew or
something but i don't get the impression
that they were so
militant as atheists as richard dawkins
is
that they basically would call it child
abuse you know to practice a religion
essentially so i think that they were
they were you know they they made
you know they had a sense of conciliance
themselves
but um in my mind she's she's truly
independent you know she
she clearly has a huge influence from
them
and and recognizes the gratitude that
she owes to her unique upbringing
okay what were their views on
extraterrestrials let me hear that
i think so yeah we talked about that in
the context of evidence because she her
whole thing is i don't believe something
unless i have scientific evidence for it
and i said well what would carl sagan
say now that it's been 60 years since
the you know original project osman
did we talk have we talked about sarah
skull's book i forgot no not yet
okay we should talk about that soon so i
referenced that because that
sasha brought up the title of her book
for
small creatures such as we comes from
the only work of fiction
that her father ever wrote which is the
book called contact
the book called contact was turned into
a movie and it sort of features a woman
uh played by jody foster and it's
representing a real colleague of mine
and friend of mine jill tarter who
actually put the
verb on my book as well and
um and so my friend sarah skulls wrote
jill tarter's biography too
and so we were talking about that and my
assertion that you know
there's been an awful lot of energy
literally and money spent on seti
without much return for it so is it
appropriate
to suspect when do you turn off the
experiment when do you shut down the
radio telescope
uh jill will always say to me well we've
only searched the equivalent of you know
a cup of water
out of the entire pacific ocean in terms
of what we could see um
on the one hand that's true but you know
it doesn't
if you do go out there and you and you
get a bigger fish tank
and you don't find anything at what
point you stop fishing
right do you go to a different fishing
hall or go to a different technology so
i think sasha's you know she's
she's kind of open to this idea almost
more as
a way that it reflects back on us on our
own psychology
and what we crave from the universe
because remember that whole universe uh
or that quote
the title of her book for small
creatures such as we uh the only thing
that makes the vast
loneliness uh bearable the emptiness of
space basically
bearable is love and that's the full
quote something like that she goes
through the quote in the interview
uh but the point being that uh people
like carl and people like sasha
they believe that there's basically
would be no meaning in the universe if
there's
if there's only um if there weren't
human beings and the capacity that we
have for love
if there are no aliens or any other
civilization outside of our own
and so i think it's a little bit wish
wishful you know hoping and i
i certainly have colleagues that study
it and i'm very deeply
uh admire jill tarter and seth shostak
and their friends
but um you know the question of of at
what point does its
you know does it take over from uh
you know from evidence-based pursuits
into as as sarah
scholes presents it almost like
religious fervor in its own sorry to
keep coming back to that
but this evidence without belief or you
know belief without evidence rather
that's a theme of her book and i i don't
think she really
fully ties it together in the sense that
you know that this is
she's not gonna say stop you know turn
off the machines and nor would i
uh because as people point out you know
we've only been looking for 60 years
on the other hand there's a lot of
volume in space out to a radius a sphere
of radius you know
a hundred light years let's just say
yeah how many point all the time
yeah yeah and and and people like adam
frank and others will say that
yeah there's no aliens with prosthetic
foreheads uh like we might have imagined
or humanoid aliens like in contact
nevertheless um you know there could be
microbes or or
shadow biosphere as paul davies and i
talked about earlier this year we should
also talk about that maybe we'll do a
whole ufo
or uh seti and plus ufo uh episode
where i cover paul davey's book they are
uh their eerie silence which is about
the failure to
to detect seti um so far and
alternatives that could explain why we
haven't seen
radio transmissions for example and
sarah scholz's book on
ufos and also making contact that would
be kind of fun a theme episode at some
point
yeah let's do that though when you can
spend the whole hour because i think
we're gonna we're gonna run out of time
real fast on that like we
yeah are coming close to now well you
know this whole idea of belief without
evidence
is uh is you know the you got to remind
people that's also
the beginning of a scientific theory
right at first you've got an idea
or a suspicion or a hypothesis of how
things might be
in nature and then you go forth you
start with a faith that this must be
true or a
a belief that this must be true and then
you continue on
with finding your evidence in support of
those
of this belief when with evidence and so
there is a there is a period there where
you're starting out with just an idea
uh yeah you know it's based on stuff but
it's still an idea
and so you need to draw that in more as
you go forward
i i guess you know carl is i don't i
never met him
and i i've of course idolized him in the
uh 70s and 80s and um
he uh you know i remember watching him
on tv all the time and um he was
fervently i think andrean was too uh
fervently anti-nuclear the big
the big scare at the time in the 80s
especially was that we were all going to
blow ourselves up and that theme
occur you know came up quite a few times
in the original cosmos series
and um he was he was he had very
passionate ideas about
certain political um uh states at the
time especially
in terms of nuclear uh power or nuclear
um weapons
and so um but i never i don't remember
him
saying anything like
um you know that that life in the
universe is inevitable or that of course
we're going to have we're going to
eventually
find life in the universe from what i
remember from all the things i've seen
him say
there was always this healthy i think
skepticism that we should keep looking
but there's no reason that we should
find anything
right and so um uh he
talked a lot about the yuri miller
experiment uh in cosmos
and and the how it how it's possible to
make all of the ingredients for life
uh relatively easy so it with the
implication being that it should be easy
to make on
other worlds and there was a whole
episode on this in the original cosmos
about what
life might be like on say jupiter
remember those big balloon creatures
that were in there were like the
animated
yeah you still see that in planetarium
shows to this day yes
i know right so there was a lot of
speculation about what these beings
might be like but i know
i think he would be okay if we were it
yeah i think so too i mean he wouldn't
be happy about it in other words he'd be
more pleased to know that life has
originated elsewhere in the
in the cosmos but i guess i wonder you
know why would that make him more happy
i mean i see two different schools so
adam frank is a professor i think in
rochester right i've had
light from the stars it's a good book
but you know he talks about basically
you know because the nearest life forms
might have only
you know destroyed themselves uh you
know 100 million years ago
we might be the only you know existing
uh
uh you know solar system that has
intelligent technological life
uh and so that should make us value life
on earth that much more
i think you know that's a blandish but
it's not like i enjoy life now i enjoy
it really more because i know i'm it and
and i think like sometimes there's a
tendency in the
in these realms to say to kind of
idolize not just nature but kind of
um not idolize the the sense that that
um you know the kinship that all
living creatures or all entities have in
the universe like i hear things like oh
it's
i'm connected to the stars as carl said
we're all star stuff but
you know because you're made of the same
thing as you know you have trace
elements of
radioactive thorium in your body do you
feel like a kinship to a nuclear reactor
no it's always are like
because you have you know some ethylene
ethylene in your bloodstream
you feel a kinship to styrofoam no
nobody does or methane okay let's take
an example well you could but
weird yeah exactly right so but it's
always like star stuff and i talk about
that the iron in your blood you know
comes from a supernova i talk about that
in my book
and we got into this poetry for
physicists that's the second clip if you
want to play that all right
i'll i'm gonna play it now yeah let's
talk because we talked a lot about art
and science
all right i'll play it now go for it
the poem but i think it is by richard
feynman it actually doesn't have a title
to it but he says poets say science
takes away from the beauty of the stars
mere globs of gas atoms i too can see
the stars in the desert night
and feel them but do i see less or more
the vastness of the heavens stretches my
imagination
stuck on this carousel my little eye
catches one
million year old light the vast pattern
of which i am apart
what is the pattern or the meaning or
the why
it does not do harm to the mystery to
know a little bit about it
for far more marvelous is the truth than
any of the artists
of the past imagined it why do the poets
of the present not speak of it
what men are poets who can speak of
jupiter if he were a man
but if he is an immense spinning sphere
of methane and ammonia
must be silent so i think i know which
one you might prefer but i'd like to
hear
from you i don't know have you ever
heard the feynman yes and i
have to say i love walden but i'm with
feynman on this one for sure i figured
you might be yeah so can you
talk about it yeah i mean so i this is
my position
is um and sometimes it's
you know it's not always the um it's the
delivery
so often when we communicate the
grandeur
of the universe and our deep
understanding
of the beauty of nature it we don't have
the passion
that you see sometimes i mean
the first version of this that comes to
mind is like
a great preacher like that enthusiasm
that thrill that joy gets lost sometimes
i think that this is the connection
between those two
between um that spine chilling thrill
and the true nature as revealed by
science
the poem but i think it is by richard
feynman i am so
glad to hear her say but he says science
takes away
and it's the passion that comes through
there are globs of gas one
you can see
i just got a tweet from sasha that i
think she's watching it or she's
she liked uh the fact that you and i are
chatting today so oh sasha if you're out
there hi there yes
leave us a comment yes most definitely
but in case you didn't hear what i just
said i want to reiterate it because it's
important
what sasha just said about her father
about delivery and the passion uh that
makes all the difference
is exactly what made her father who he
was um i could listen to him all day
long
especially just talking about science
because the words he used the cadence
the
the passion the pauses all of it was
what made him who he was and i was
enthralled by him
he could talk about anything and i would
listen to it because of the belief yeah
me too and
and i and i talked to her about that too
and i and i said you know
there is sort of a hierarchy where you
know scientists who do that who
popularize
are sometimes not as as um well
respected maybe by their
more um you know kind of lab oriented or
you know just just more insular
colleagues and i feel like that's a
disservice
that we have this burden that if you're
good at communicating you're perceived
as
less as a scientist so famously her
father was never
elected that's right to the national
academy of sciences even though
on the scientific grounds he deserved it
uh and then you add on
he won like communicator awards and
things like that now the first person
says that awards are relatively
meaningless but in that case it was
it was a slight it was like you know
saying you cannot win it because you're
so good at communicating i remember that
yep i do he was a real son you know he
was like in the same vein as a brian
greene or you know
tyson will and i are not like practicing
scientists they're they're wonderful
communicators and that's
that's their job in life but you know
what carl was was this was a true
scientist who
happened to be balanced on both sides of
his brain and i can't remember what
brain that makes you if you know if
you're good and in communication
versus if you're good at scientific hard
qual quantitative factual details
well you know both him and and where
some of the are some and
he still is and and carl was one of the
most articulate people
you could ever run across um it just
like they just had a very high
vocabulary a very interesting way of
putting
uh complex uh topics into into
images that we could see in our heads
and that is a gift man that is such a
gift and i've
gotta miss really you know i really miss
god
i never met him i almost met him because
both sasha and my father were both
professors at cornell they overlapped
briefly for a couple years in the late
late 70s late 60s but um but thinking
about him and and this notion of
of communication i had another
conversation last week so this this
video came out you know as a mother's
day special
for father's day i'm going to have a
two-part special actually i'll have part
of it before father's day with eric
weinstein
who has another controversial new theory
of physics and unification of physics
called geometric unity
we'll talk a lot about that but one of
his most strident and ardent demands is
basically that we improve as
physicist uh especially as theoretical
physicist or
our theoretical astrophysicist that we
he demands you know kind of
that we get more funding but that we
also behave in a way to
uh to advocate on our own behalf to be
worthy of increased funding
like we have the most interesting ideas
according to eric
and the worst possible pr and
presentation so
that was a three hour interview that was
actually my longest interview so we're
going to split into two
half we'll put up uh maybe in a week or
so and half will put up on father's day
because he and i
discussed for a long time his feelings
on fatherhood
legacy and all sorts of things and um i
thought it was
it'll make a nice father's day kind of
uh two-part episode
okay great well um all right so well i
guess brian we're out of time but uh
so uh the interview with uh sausage
sagan and the power of secular ritual
his interview with the link is in the
description box
go to his channel watch the interview
the link to buying sasha's book is also
in both my description and
in uh brian uh brian's description box
as well so you can check out her new
book or
this is her first book isn't it her yeah
that's her first book
she's going to work on a second book she
said we didn't get into too much detail
about it but
um but yeah you're absolutely right yeah
she's she's an incredible author very
lyrical
writer very touching and very intimate
and i like that
yeah good bye enough an author yeah well
i don't watch the interviews before i
talk to you because i want to get the
preview like everybody else is so
yeah i'm gonna go watch the interview uh
the one with mario by the way
outstanding mario was great as always i
love him so yeah
okay guys all right well brian uh you
can go ahead and head out if you need to
don't forget to
hit the stop streaming button
on your channel uh i'm gonna stick
around in case tony you know it goes off
i i may go off on something i'm gonna
say what he thinks of californians as
soon as i leave he's gonna
oh yeah oh i do hate california i do hey
san diego's not so bad but the valley oh
man the la in the valley i i can't stand
that so
all right so yeah i'm gonna everybody
thanks so much next week i think we're
off but in two weeks let's talk
oh um i got it actually i got an email
from the double a s
saying that they had to push it back so
we can do next week if you're free
um sorry i'm i'm interviewing jan 11 uh
i think at this time so let's figure out
another let's let's coordinate by email
and uh we'll figure out either way i'll
accept i'll show up and say something
so i'll be here next week all right i
really enjoy it out there everybody send
questions
subscribe to the uh podcast on itunes
please leave a rating and a review
because actually the algorithm that
youtube that uh that apple uses to
promote it
uh depends on how many reviews and
ratings that we have so i'll i'll leave
a
um i'll leave a link to it right now in
the in the chat box
and then please um uh please rate and
review it that'll do me a big favor
don't ask for much but that's it yeah
yeah that's a good idea and um
you can get it on spotify too though
right you can watch it correct yeah yeah
yeah yeah and on our websites and so
forth yeah
okay cool all right brian i'll see you
soon sign off thank you guys
okay dr brian talk to you later
all right i will um i'll just chat with
you guys for a while
so yeah i decided not to stream on
twitch today
because i'm trying i'm an affiliate on
twitch and